we're gonna bring in dr. Siegel right
now Fox News medical contributor here to
talk about some of these key issues as
they relate to coronavirus dr. Siegel
welcome back as always what do you make
a good morning to you what do you make
of the impact of these ships the mercy
the comfort and what kind of effect they
will have on in terms of the ability of
these hot spots to deal with the disease
well first of all as the president just
said the United States Navy ship comfort
a thousand bed hospital with 12
operating rooms
I see use radiology suites labs 5,000
units of blood is going to bring here a
spirit of courage the United States
military of hope and assistance and it's
going to mean that not that non kovat
patients patients that don't have this
virus will be able to get traumatic
services emergency and urgent surgeries
and care outside of the hospitals of New
York City which will free them up
Jedidiah for us to focus in on not just
care for the for the virus patients but
to separate them out properly to observe
proper infectious precautions and to get
our health care workers properly
outfitted that will take a tremendous
amount of pressure off and we're all
going to be inspired to see the ship
come here to New York tomorrow through
New York Harbor
yeah doctor sir can I ask one follow-up
question doctor subpoenaed asked this
question earlier to another guest about
the concern that someone with
coronavirus could potentially get on one
of those ships obviously those ships are
designated for non coronavirus patients
do you think they will adequately be
able to prevent that because that's my
first thought is that somebody gets on
there has unclear symptoms has not had a
test gets into the ship and then
suddenly you have corona virus spreading
on the ship that would be a huge problem
though there's two things that come to
mind first is the word triage they
shouldn't be bringing patients to that
ship that have viral or respiratory or
symptoms that could be corona virus it
should be for things like broken bones
for surgeries not for that the second
thing that's related to that is I really
want this rapid point of service point
of care test in place that Avot has made
where we literally can test people
within five minutes
and decide if they have it or they don't
we use light spread and use of that
right away that will that will help
can't get on this can't get on the ship
until you take it might be a way to do
it but their news yesterday was the
potentially the President may take a
step to do an enforceable quarantine of
New York New Jersey and Connecticut
later in the day the president clarified
here's part of the tweet that he sent
out about the the move they're making he
said on the recommendation of the White
House coronavirus task force and upon
consultation with the governors of New
York New Jersey and Connecticut I've
asked the CDC to issue a strong travel
advisory to be administered by the
governors in consultation with the
federal government a quarantine will not
be necessary
the CDC followed up with with more
direct guidelines and this is what it
says that due to the extensive community
transmission of covin 19 in the area CDC
urges residents of New York New Jersey
and Connecticut to refrain from
non-essential domestic travel for 14
days effective immediately
doctor your reaction is a travel
advisory right now the right way to go
and what impact will it have I think
it's hugely important Pete right now
when you consider that this 52,000 cases
in New York State alone and that also
has additional cases in the outlying
areas to try it what we call the
tri-state area New York Connecticut in
New Jersey we need to clamp down on
travel and really restrict people stay
staying at home sheltering in place very
very careful travel for only essential
means but we need it for essential means
to keep what's left of our economy going
so it's important I think the right
decision was made strict travel
advisories and I would urge everyone
who's watching us to follow them because
we don't need more cases right now our
hospitals here in New York for example
are completely overwhelmed
well dr. Siegel all our viewers
certainly appreciate what you and the
other doctors have been doing which is
answering the questions from our viewers
let me read you an email we got from Dan
and see if we can answer this and help
him out he says is it true increased
indoor humidity can decrease coronavirus
transmission you know that's an
excellent question Grif and there was
actually a study from the CDC Centers
for Disease Control back in 2013 that
did show that humid
our indoors decreases how far
respiratory viruses can travel so I
think it's a really good idea that you
have you Madera humidifier in your house
right now it's not a cure-all but it's a
very positive step and we're also hoping
that warm you would air outside will
also decrease the spread of this we're
hoping that that spring will bring hope
in that regard we also have a question
from Elizabeth on Facebook if people are
smoking or vaping does the smoke they
exhale carry the virus so that's another
excellent question from our producers
but I don't think so but I'll tell you
something I'll tell you why I don't
think so because it's not airborne
it's a respiratory droplet so it
shouldn't travel on vapor or smoke its
respiratory droplet only it's not
hovering in the air over you but I want
everyone out there to know that vaping
and smoking damages your lungs in ways
that make it more likely that you would
have a serious case now is the time to
quit not yes not tomorrow now it will
help if you god forbid get this you
would likely have a milder case doctor
one more quick question email from Jack
says can the new five minute test you
talked about doctor for Kovan 19 be
adapted to the drive through process so
people find out right away you know I
will be talking to Admiral jor or from
from HHS about that this week and I am
hoping the answer to that is yes I'm
certain they're going to be doing more
rapid testing those five hour lines with
with the big nasal swabs now it's a much
thinner easier to use swab and the
results in five to thirteen minutes
should definitely be used on those
mobile units definitely and will cut
down dramatically those tests can do
50,000 patients a day that's what we
need here in the United States right now
that will help us to separate people out
who have kovin 19 from the general
population that will help to squash this
dr. mark Siegel thank you so much for
your time this morning your expertise we
really appreciate it great stuff for our
viewers